thank you
[Music]
so welcome back to careful boys we're
very careful boys we're currently off
the Record today we're talking about
guys and the dating World keep on
letting them [__] down
[__] are hard to please what can I
say yeah they are hard to please tell me
about it as an owner of one almost
impossible [__] owner yeah I'm gonna
take some out I've owned a few [__]
and they're really hard own and operate
owner operator owner and operator wow
you got your Supra ring for your
engagement yeah refurbished
uh every three years okay or the wear
and tear gets messes with their brain
you gotta put freon in it what was the
question the real question
uh guys just keep on letting all the
[__] down anymore yeah
yeah and I think it's something might
come
um dating is more difficult now yeah
difficult as in like it's changing it's
the the way that it's been done just
even pre-covered I feel like it's
changed post covered how to change the
postcode in your observations because
you were actually I dated during covet
which was that was already a [__]
huge one because even if you're on
dating apps or anything like it's like
now you're like
well should we you know meet up during
this time because it's also it was it it
depends if it's like fresh lockdown
right no one's actually meeting no yes
that's socially accepted yeah but toward
the end like everybody was just breaking
rules yeah yeah but in the very
beginning it was just like people were
just chatting online or whatever and
then like I think people had to
be good DM game and then you had long
conversations long talks whatever
and then like toward the end it was it
just seemed like everybody was just
hooking up yeah
but I don't know
I definitely feel like it changed from
like pre where people did the whole like
let's meet up let's talk let's hang out
let's have a good time let's date
I mean people still hooked up but it
seemed like more people were having
relationships
what did you do in how did you [__] up
do you think in your your time dating
[__] during covet
I don't know I didn't maybe wasn't the
mentality that I had
the I I do think I had a more uh Hot Boy
Summer mentality okay
I think I think you're International too
you're going [__] worldwide dude
sorry
[Laughter]
it's a veteran
I I say yes we do [__] these hoes
no
um
maybe more people were just like
I see all these failed relationships
around me what's the point so you you
have a bunch of guys that are either
just not trying at all like apathy or
guys that are just like
I just want the [__]
maybe I think it's also I think it's
more so that either they don't know what
they want or they just want to hook up
and very very few people are
intentionally dating to marry or
division really
yeah find their match
yeah and by the way look we titled this
video in a juicy way about guys letting
[__] down but it's both people you
know it's both yeah
yeah yeah we know we got to use the
click bait yeah but no so so your
experience has been similar to that like
our guys not trying or what what yeah I
think guys I think a majority of them I
think are more in like the hookup
mindset
um and I think there are very few select
people I haven't met them yet that are
intentionally dating with the purpose of
truly trying to find their match do you
and getting to know someone do you think
these guys they all fit in in a certain
age group or like maybe even phase in
their life like have you noticed I mean
I don't know Filipino or just like
Filipino boys Filipinos they're all
Chinese they're all Asian really no no I
can only speak on my experience yeah
um but I mean I date between
my agent up but it's usually I stay a
little bit older like at least three
four years older
um and they seem like they don't or it
looks just crazy like yeah that's crazy
there's there's men out there who are 35
36 37 who are I think have either given
up
um they have lost all sense of like what
it means to be a man how to like plan a
date how to like like jaded somebody be
intentional with their time
um are you looking for that like
traditional kind of like chivalrous dude
that like yeah like the dude that plans
the day opens the door shows up on time
well it sounds like it's like
traditional bare minimum upstairs yeah
yeah show up that's crazy the guy I'm
wondering what like just the standard
it's just like that's not even it moves
anymore when you talk to your your other
girlfriends are they all experienced
it's like across the board a lot of
dudes are just not even upholding the
standard for like 10 years I mean the
people that I do know are in
relationships oh I see so like but
they've been in relationships for years
it's like you guys you guys have been in
a relationship forever you know seven
eight plus years so it's a little bit
different
I wonder if the guys act like that
because they can like they're still
getting dates they're still getting
girls and then so they don't have to try
so that
they do act like well it's also the
girls fault too and I also think it's
maybe a big city thing
I think it's also like partly the
Women's Hall big city mentality and
social media has a big aspect to do with
that as well is that these girls are now
getting uh more attention than ever
through social media so they feel like
they have more leverage to just go out
with these guys get a free meal do this
take advantage of them and now guys are
feeling taken advantage of so they're
like why the [__] am I gonna plan [__]
for these girls who are just taking
advantage of me how do I know you're
worthy yeah then why go out on a date
right but it's just like because he's
hoping that you're different but it's
like you have to prove it to him I mean
my my rule of thumb is like if if you're
searching if you're intentional and you
know what you want you're searching for
that thing just be that thing regardless
of what you that's really good advice
yeah it is yeah so it's like don't let
the world
change who you are because you're
reacting to well all the girls are going
to be like this well I'm not going to be
like myself anymore and don't front
because they can smell it bro but if
you're genuinely a kind person that
wants to just continuously give and
doing that then it's like who cares then
you're not getting burnt if that's who
you are pretty hard though too because
like man you can get defeated really
quickly yeah you know being that person
and just being take it for granted over
and over yeah every letdown is another
you know it's just like well damn like
what am I even doing this build a jaded
defense mechanism and then you then it's
just a bunch of jaded people dating
other jaded people right so it's just
like a big [__] up ecosystem and
you're just trying to pick through the
trash and
red flag at that point you're not good
for anything else yeah I think they're
not in a mindset of like intentionally
getting to know somebody because you're
just like trying to pick out the red
flag yes I've seen that so much it's
called Toluca Lake
there's a I do I do remember the reason
why I didn't like dating that much in La
was there was already like this
auditioning feeling of hey I'm cool
you're cool we're normal
that you know that feeling of like don't
worry like you gotta pass that phase of
like oh I'm not gonna [__] you over of
like and it if you're already coming at
that it's not a playful environment it's
more like what do you got for me that's
the feeling you got yeah what can I get
okay yeah it's like are you are you
worthy of me but then at the same time I
think like um
maybe that type of person is just not
attracted to me in general because then
I'm really quick to decide whether I can
have fun with this person or not and if
they're not interesting immediately I'm
just like okay I see where you're at
where your mind is at and I can smell
the insecurity or whatever is going on
whereas other people might be more
patient right where they're going
through these activities and then maybe
she'll be like can you buy me dinner and
then he's like yeah sure and then he's
like wait I thought we had a
relationship going on she goes no I just
wanted dinner and he's like oh [__] you
then right really like there's
situations like that where yeah I've
seen
straight up right in front of me and
this has in on a smaller scale has
happened to me but with my friends we're
we're just in a group like maybe double
dating or whatever and the new girl that
they're with they'll see something and
be like oh that's so cool you're gonna
buy that for me someday just straight up
really yeah and I'm like oh but they're
acting like that because Sims do buy
[__] for them so that's not her fault
either replacing expectations yeah and
you're just looking at it or operating
it from a different angle right so I
don't know I think
I think for those who actually want to
find somebody and build a life with
somebody and be intentional I think it's
really hard right now to do that I think
there's a lot of people who are in the
um
convenience what can I get out of this
what can you do for me and um to fill a
void too A lot of people are just
feeling voids
so if you wanted a long-term
relationship you never tried that in a
small town
[Laughter]
but the funny thing is like I feel like
small country small town not major city
people are getting married in their
early 20s yeah that's true it's just
it's just different right that that's a
different lifestyle most of my friends
and even if they are long-term
relationship friends like they don't get
married until they're mid to late 30s
they don't start popping trying to have
kids until they're mid to late 30s like
and these are from people who are
relationship type people I just think
the big city you kind of push it off I
think there's a process to it too I
think people also go into
we're dating as soon as we start talking
we're dating I think there's a there's a
talking phase of like who are you do I
even like you as a person before I even
want to consider dating you let alone
then getting into a relationship with
you then getting serious with you right
I think people just go just because
we're talking or you know we ate
somewhere one time and we split the bill
or something we're dating it's just like
no yeah yeah that's just not what it is
there's also a stigma against like uh
going into the Friendship phase because
I think it's immediately friend zone but
my opinion is you actually have to
become friends first that's true before
you categorize you have so much more
possibility yeah because it's like okay
first we're friends like we're people
that just are enjoyable together before
we figure out if we're best friends or
if we're gonna be romantic or if we're
gonna just be oh we're just rock
climbing buddies or like you know like I
feel like the people they're so scared
of that they're like I just want to get
to the [__] and then they want to
like just skip like this whole like get
into no no buy a house you through it
first right yeah you want to walk
through them girls you imagine yourself
there yeah [__] the couch yeah same [__]
Anthony this is a four bedroom
but that goes back to dating with
intention right dating with the fact of
like I know what I want I know what I'm
looking for in somebody and I'm willing
to play the long game and in hopes of
finding something substantial yeah one
of my buddies he was on the apps and he
was saying on his side it just feels
like because you could just find another
date to go through
[Music]
um
it's like when you watch Netflix and
you're just like I don't know what to
watch you're like oh that's a good movie
that's good and you just keep going and
you just never find anything you know
like it's because it's so like it's
almost too accessible to the point where
it doesn't really mean anything if you
go on a date with somebody and be like
well I don't really like them oh well I
have three other days it's like hitting
a buzzer and it's like okay next more
like disagreements now or Now red flags
which I think that's like a problem too
because then it's like okay well now
we're disagreeing okay therefore it's a
red flag we're gonna toss this person
out yeah and I'm just gonna go find the
next person so now you're not even
getting through the process of truly
knowing this person oh they're toxic
because they don't agree with everything
right well now yeah your partner is not
going to agree with everything
especially now that politics are so
ingrained 20 years later yeah yeah
serious people are just like there's a
lack of standard of of chivalry of being
a gentleman of being a lady
um and then also just basic
communication skills just basic skills
of getting to know somebody friendship
skills I think like honestly the people
in general have kind of lost their mind
which in turn turned the dating pool
into kind of a [__] well honestly
to like sometimes people just don't
realize like women I think do such a
good job of being a mommy for me that
like me yeah that I get you know I get
excited about it yeah
[Laughter]
and you tell me
how where to get you out of town
what
it says
0 I'm not used this kind of delay it
smells like me dude
oh he's showing her who's the Boss
what is he German
oh you know they don't [__] around with
time though when you're four minutes
late on the German that's like being two
hours that's a good accent but also like
what is
running a few minutes late four minutes
late like four minutes late that's
that's ridiculous a lot of late four but
you don't understand Germans though four
times four four minutes late to them is
it's so bad it's so bad imagine being on
a date with this chicky like what the
[__] is wrong with you it's four bit
four man are you stupid do you not know
how to tell time time during their lunch
he's just talking about that for the
next 30. exactly and then he's like so
we doing this again what's going on yeah
yeah you didn't text me back really
great time so you know the the statistic
about
um 50 of marriages turn into divorces
right it's actually not true the way
that you see it it's not brand new
marriages first time marriages it's
people been married really most of that
is people on their second or third or
it's multiple so
yeah so it's actually I I it I was
losing hope because I was thinking damn
so many divorces every year but what it
is is it's people that constantly fail
in marriages that are constantly
divorced there's like one like one guy
can have five divorces this is a poll on
people who are constantly being failed
marriages no no they're just saying a
divorce rate they're saying that the
divorce rate is 50 right so they're just
looking at the number of them look a
little bit deeper you're like this guy
deeper you break it down there's so many
more new jobs
people that are like okay this is a vast
majority of that the data is deeper yeah
so it's like if you if you think about
the first time people are divorced and
it's actually very very small and out of
that group if they're remarrying they
add to the divorce rate yeah because
they're just looking at how many
divorces happen every year yeah and then
so like that made me go wait so actually
so the majority is still relationships
that work out yeah and so I had this
whole mentality of like well if half of
the uh statistics is everyone ends up in
divorce and that means like it's really
hard well I mean it is hard but then
it's like that just tells me that
where's the Hope in marriage and things
like that when you hear stupid stats
like that but it's actually not the
majority
you could look at that camera and just
talk to 10 of the last dudes you dated
what's some advice you would give them
oh yeah what would you tell them uh
consistency and effort
that makes it's a huge thing
help like consistency as in hell like
um like your word is your bond right
at least mine is that's like one of my
principles so
um
don't be four minutes late
um ever in just even the smallest things
like it doesn't mean need to be like a
gift-giving situation it just needs to
be like you remembered I said something
I show that you care you know that
you're listening you listened
um and then consistency in your
character like don't let that switch up
too much over time so you think they're
playing
like a role that they think you would I
think a lot of people in the dating pool
really good First Act they yeah they put
on an impression or they morph into a
person that they think that you like oh
geez and that's really easy to sniff
I've seen that yeah and it's like you're
more agreeable but now you're just
unsexy now yeah versus I'd rather you'd
rather be someone that's slightly more
disagreeable but this guy has cajones
and I'm actually this is different
opinions have a take don't suck but yeah
have a [__] opinion a good take yeah
true yeah you know what's you know
what's an interesting feeling too you
know like the uh you know this game
shows where they go hey you can win this
or you can have what's behind door
number two like door number two dating
now like because like you know the
feeling when you go to a new school or
you're in a new improv group it's like
everyone's dateable and then you start
to get to know people you're like
actually no I wouldn't date you I
wouldn't date you and then you figure
out like which ones are kind of your
thing now it's like you'll you're
perpetually out of [__] Buffet yeah
because everything's literally Within
Reach and it must be kind of like
overwhelming yeah because everyone you
date is like like commit with her that
I'm gonna I might miss out on some other
[__] you look at all the negatives
before also I think people know how to
deal with challenges or problems anymore
it's all red flags
that's a red flag or you're you're you
have a lot of trauma or like you're
projecting it's like yeah everybody does
everybody everybody we're all human we
all have then once you and once you've
actually been in a long-term
relationship you realize that some of
the biggest maybe disagreements that
you're able to fix and heal has not
become one of the biggest like backbones
the depth that you can build is
unbelievable if you give yourself the
chance but yeah so many people just
can't wait for door number two yeah yeah
but yeah that's what I'm waiting for
somebody who's in the same place
mentally and is willing to put in the
effort and consistency to find that and
they got that good dick huh yeah
[Music]
the other parts I'm working on but the
good dig part I kind of I kind of got it
dig and everything else kind of was like
mid and I was like all right I'm out
good dick and good mouth yeah yeah
all the central crisis he's like I
thought my dick was good and I was like
wow what if the subject line says it
says good dick but with 27 u's
27 years between G and D there's 27
years
do you open it or do you skip if he
doesn't put three eyes in dick then I'll
I will go
that's how I know you'll take the guy
with floss
maybe you can't read or write listen I
did I have signs and a big D at the end
fresh
fish
at least five hundred thousand dollars a
year let's go and
um what else he needs to be like an
alpha yeah and he likes design high
value man it needs to be at least six
nine and he has to play
you know what's funny is like I see them
on social media I never [__] run into
these people where do they exist yeah
they're the crazy like people that speak
crazy like that yeah like where are
these [__] the girls that ask for
that the standards like I don't hear of
girls at like I don't know the gym
[__] going at the [__] club
where's the six nines that that make
half a million dollars a year I knew an
actor chick like that but it was just
one chick but she was definitely like
that yeah yeah I don't know
in energy yeah if you if you really ask
them but the ones who really feel that
way are afraid to say it too